the president is continuing these corona
rallies
large crowds very few masks
no social distancing certainly no
coronavirus tests
the latest one was at winston-salem
north carolina's airport
airport rallies now are something trump
is doing so he can just
fly in get off the plane and do the
rally
and then fly back out and this stuff
really matters from the standpoint of
the virus on the bonus show today we're
going to talk about a new study
which suggests that 250 000 coronavirus
cases
a significant portion of all august
coronavirus cases
were spread by the sturgis motorcycle
rally in
south dakota i believe it's not north no
south dakota
um so these events have a real world
impact
let's look at some of the moments from
yesterday's very very much unhinged
rally donald trump started the rally
by actually bragging about how many
people there were again
during a pandemic no social distancing
very few masks trump bragging about it
we said let's keep it down they didn't
do too good a job but that's good right
that's good now these crowds i tell you
it's beyond what we had in terms of
enthusiasm beyond what we had four years
ago in 2016
and that was a record enthusiasm and we
are breaking that record by a lot this
is the most
important election we've ever had and
speaking of which by the way
uh at this rally where
there are barely any masks people are
packed together
you really shouldn't have more than 10
people in a crowd and there are
thousands
donald trump attacks nancy pelosi
because she
went to a salon without wearing a mask
nancy pelosi with her hair dryer in the
whole thing
[Applause]
everybody has to wear a mask you must
keep all beauty parlors closed
then she's in her beauty brother with no
mask oh
and then she said the the biggest the
biggest person she could have said okay
she said you got me but she said i got
set up by the beauty parlor owner who
happens to be a trump person by the way
i like the beauty parlor first
she said i got set up by the owner of
the beauty parlor now
set me up i said how are you going to do
with putin kim jong-un and president xi
of china
no it's terrible she's always preaching
about the mask you've got to wear the
mask at all times indoor outdoor
when you go to bed at night
put the mask on i've spent the last four
years keeping my promises
now what nancy pelosi did was stupid
i've already said you know
when these are the rules in california
you're not supposed to have salons open
she has the money to have someone come
to her house but
who is trump to be criticizing her for
not wearing a mask
when he's holding a rally in the middle
of a pandemic where people are crushed
crushed together it makes absolutely no
sense
whatsoever uh this is the president of
the united states speaking by the way
this this is the the embarrassment is
not just what he is saying
it's that this is the president and this
is how they speak
then trump went into his performative
mispronunciations of kamala harris's
name
and he starts it's all it's almost like
some kind of gregorian
chanting that donald trump starts take a
look at this by the way
you know who's further left than crazy
bernie kamala
kamala kamala i'm not completely sure
but i'm erring on the side of this
probably being xenophobic in some way do
you guys agree disagree i'm not sure
then donald trump went into the victim
complex
and this is just so out of touch one of
the most powerful men
in the world the height of privilege the
epitome
of wealth um donald trump again doing
the victim complex saying that
he has been treated even worse than
abraham lincoln by the press
this is really weird take a look
and actually if we weren't interrupted
with
constant investigations that went
nowhere
and nobody has been through what i've
been through as president of the united
states nobody
you know they used to say abraham
lincoln got the worst press i said
there's no way he got worse than me
but lincoln was very very badly treated
by the fake news
maybe in his case it was real i can tell
you in my case it's fake
it's totally fake but nobody's been and
it should never be allowed to happen
again let's see what happens we caught
him cold let's see what happens
[Music]
but if we didn't have to you know that
takes time and energy
and all of the things the time that we
spent on this
impeachment hoax this is kind of like
trump's i did more for black people than
anyone except maybe lincoln
now he's been treated worse than any
president except maybe
abraham lincoln or maybe actually worse
than abraham lincoln absolutely and
completely bizarre
and then donald trump took this sort of
victim complex
and smoothly transit smoothly as
smoothly as donald trump can
transition when alternating between
reading a teleprompter and ranting
um he transitioned into suggesting that
his supporters
sign up to be poll watchers on election
day and he warned the crowd
about the stealing and the robbing and
the thieving
that he expects to see it polling places
i guess trump is warning the crowd
about pickpocketing at polling places
take a look
look at these crowds and if they're
going to cheat crowds they're
meaningless really
if they're going to cheat these big
beautiful crowds you can have 15
000 you could have 50 000. these crowds
are meaningless watch it
be pole watches when you go there watch
all the thieving and stealing
and robbing they do because this is
important we win north carolina we win
we're going to win florida i just left
florida we're going to win florida
i have to tell you i didn't think that
polling places were unsafe
places it's an interesting idea but it's
not much like we don't hear much about
in-person voter fraud because it
essentially doesn't exist
i've never even heard about theft
burglary
pickpocketing and thieving at polling
places unless donald trump is of course
getting back to this idea of a rigged
election which he probably is
and then hear donald trump waxing
philosophical uh to the extent that he
can
imagining 1 000 years into the future
that his wall which hasn't been built
will still be seen as a marvel of of
human innovation take a look
two things if you come back in a
thousand years two thousand years or
three thousand years
if you're lucky enough assuming we have
something with with the world is a crazy
place isn't it
but if you come back in a thousand years
there are two things with all the
computers and all the everything changes
every day
you invent a new cell you invent a new
laptop
everything is obsolete like about two
weeks after you invented right
two things that will never get obsolete
the wall
and the wheel right
the wheel trump has nothing to do with
the wall
isn't being built and no i don't think
that a thousand years from now
we will still think of a wall between
the u.s and mexico
if it exists as some kind of timeless
marvel
or the vanguard of human technology and
innovation you know we
humans are notoriously bad at predicting
the future humans are notorious
notoriously bad at making economic
predictions
but i feel pretty confident that if a
wall is built between the us and mexico
in a thousand years it will not be a
notable
technological innovation at the time
then trump just starts making things up
about the wall
again going back to mexico is going to
pay for the wall you might not get how
but trump is insisting mexico will pay
for the wall
and you know mexico is paying for the
wall just so you understand
they don't say that they never say it
but we're going to charge a small fee at
the border
you know the toll booths we have topos
so that it's the biggest border in the
world in terms of people going across
and in terms of industry believe it or
not the southern border
we're putting a small toll on and maybe
we're going to do something with
remittance that's where people come here
make money and they send it back
so we'll do something and we're going to
get all the money that we spent in the
mall
wall will be coming back so remember i
used to say
who's going to pay for it they'd say
mexico life that's right
that's right
the fact that trump says this is wild
the fact that a crowd cheers for it is
even more outrageous
there is not going to be a toll there is
it's just not going to happen
mexico is not paying for the wall and
there is no wall
there is no wall donald trump promising
so
trump has it under eight weeks left
to accomplish the promise of a wall
across the entire border during his
first term
eight weeks something like 250 miles
of wall have been replaced that's what's
happened
i don't think he's going to make it then
trump again
brings up this very dystopian idea
of patriotic education this this is
really wacky stuff you see what's going
on we will restore
patriotic education to our schools
oh you know what i'm talking about look
at you
this is a very sophisticated group tom
you know what i'm talking about
patriotic education
well the first thing they do is they
want to take your history away
we really don't know what that is and
donald trump has been talking about
restoring
patriotic education for a while now for
a while now in
in schools and what we gather
is that trump wants to correct
what he believes are lies about
racism and slavery i guess that he
claims are being told in schools
he wants to correct that this is his
term not mine
with what he says would be patriotic
education
it's out of this world cuckoo for cocoa
puffs that's the reality
uh and then maybe getting down to the to
the sort of wind down
of again like a 70-minute speech the
crowd visibly bored people on their
phones just going on way too long
donald trump is painting a picture
pre-coronavirus of an america
that had fixed its partisan division
donald trump
acting as if his leadership and his
successes prior to coronavirus were so
out of this world that they had brought
together left and right
when in reality he was impeached and
partisan divisions were worse than ever
take a look at this
and you know what after we get in we're
going to have tremendous success
and it was building we were at a point
we were so successful before the
plague came in from china we were so
successful
that we were starting to get together
people forget
we were starting success brings people
together it was so good
our jobs numbers were so good and
whether
whether it was the black community the
hispanic community the asian community
our jobs were so good our numbers were
so good
this was one of the least president
at least popular presidents ever
historically
in the gallup tracking poll approval
tracking poll
trump never got to 50 approval
even one day of his presidency and in
fact his election
spurred some of the largest protesters
uh protests in the united states in a
long time
generating more protesters than we have
seen in a very very long time and
importantly
trump lost the popular vote 3 million 3
million more people
voted for hillary clinton than the
number that voted for donald trump and
trump is
framing himself as having bridged the
political divide
up until the coronavirus hit fantasy
world
irresponsible to do the rally outrageous
that we have a president who speaks like
this
the world is laughing at us and yet and
yet
he may get four more years he may get
four more years and we're going to know
very soon
continue uh coverage continued coverage
of yesterday's rally we'll be on our
instagram
page davidpakmanshow on instagram make
sure you're following us there
i want to take a second to tell you
about one of our sponsors susman and han
sussman and han has everything you need
when it comes to face masks and other
protective gear for covid19
and they're giving my audience 20 off
sussman and han is the company that i
personally have been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell
that's actually why i reached out to
them about being a sponsor i have
tried tons of different masks this year
and i still have not found a mask
that's more comfortable or easier to
breathe in than the washable cotton
masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cotton
that feels great on your skin
it has convenient adjustable straps it
features a disposable five layer
particle filter made of activated carbon
they also have disposable cloth masks
which are really comfortable as well as
other gear
like face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers
and all of their prices are very
reasonable i also love sussman and han
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to healthcare institutions they're
a great company
you can get there by going to
davidpakman.com
mask the link is underneath this video
and you can save
20 off of everything in their store
when you use the coupon code david